[MUSIC PLAYING]
FABIO NONATO: To start off with
a little bit about who we are,
I am one of the leaders in
the Data Science and Analytics
team at Baker Hughes.
ALEX IANKOULSKI: My
name is Alex Iankoulski.
I'm a principal architect for
Data Science and Analytics
at Baker Hughes, a GE company.
And we also have
Arun on the slide.
He's the person who inspired
us to do everything that we're
going to show you today.
FABIO NONATO: Yeah.
So let's get into it.
A little bit about our
business and our challenges
and, actually, how that
gets us some opportunities.
When we talk about the oil
and gas industry in the energy
business, we're talking
about an industry that runs
on an aging fleet of assets.
And now, usually
those are running
at their optimal condition.
And that might be because
of when or how they were
commissioned several years ago.
Attached to that, the fact that
a downtime in the oil and gas
industry is very costly.
You really don't want
to have a platform,
like the one shown on the
screen, go down in production.
Because that can cost you
tens of millions of dollars
a day in lost production.
So you attach to that the
fact that the industry
is ripe for digitalization
and can leverage
a lot of what we build
as AI and machine
learning for predictive
maintenance or asset
optimization.
And you get large
opportunities to deploy
orchestrated analytics at scale.
But what is the data
that's going to fuel
all of this digitalization?
So I come from the renewables
industry, actually.
And there's a very stark
difference between this oil
and gas data rich industry
and what I was used to.
I could literally fit, in
one single flash drive--
64 gigabytes-- a whole year's
worth of operation data
from a midsize wind farm.
And here, one platform
like that, it's
going to generate
terabytes of data every day
from tens of thousands
of sensors that
are recording every second
and putting that data down
into an [INAUDIBLE].
Just as a comparison to a
usual transactional database,
that get you about 10 or 100x
more volume in data recorded.
So when we talk about
predictive maintenance,
when we talked about applying
AI and machine learning
to these opportunities,
every time we try
to find one of those events or
malfunctions that would lead
to a downtime, it's like
trying to find a needle, not
in a haystack, but in an ocean.
It's something that you
shouldn't be having every day.
So it's something
that is not there
for you to necessarily
model easily.
So how do we do this?
How do we go about understanding
and orchestrating analytics
for the oil and gas industry?
So I want to give you
guys a sense of what
is the playing field
for us in oil and gas.
So we are built on
an industry that
is built on top of
legacy systems, right?
So that gravitates
you towards a lot
of silos of different things,
meaning silos of data,
meaning silos of
code and analytics,
even runtime, OSes,
everything disparate
and separate.
So first thing we
need to do is actually
to tackle unifying that.
So for us to put all of
it into a single roof,
we come up with this
unified catalog that
tried to contextualize
all the dependencies
between those
heterogeneous types
so we can actually get
logic around the analytics
that we're going to put
forward for our customers.
So then when we have this
catalog that contextualized
what a model should be modeling
what a data represents,
we can build and connect those
and create an orchestration.
That's what we're
going to deploy.
And that's what we're going
to be talking about today.
So these orchestrations
are what we
call Analytics Orchestrations.
And right now, it's,
for me, is, I guess,
good for describing what
analytics means to us.
Analytics actually
means the realization--
the end-to-end
realization-- from data
to a key performance
indicator of business metrics
that are going to drive some
insights through our customers,
meaning we're going
to get your data.
We're going to get the
proper model that represents
your system and put
forward the information
that you're looking for.
These orchestrations
would normally
connect old DLLs, modern
Python code, even golang.
And push the results
into a deployment
where our users can interact.
Now once you have
this deployment,
you can actually
observe what your users
are doing with
both the analytics,
the data, the results.
And that's what we leverage
to learn and inform back
the semantics of our catalog.
So this is the
first loop that I'm
going to be showing you today.
And you're going to
see that over the talk,
I'm going to talk
a lot about loops.
And just to put a side
note here, for us,
orchestrating analytics,
orchestrating AI,
it's basically a
non-DAG process.
There are loops,
there are cycles
you have to learn every time
you have something running.
So let's talk about analytics
in a usual data science type
workflow.
If you go and talk
to a data scientist,
you can try to zone in
into an application that
is very linear,
but would represent
the usual atomic level of their
work, which is getting a data
set, pre-processing the data
set into something that they can
feed into a heavy
compute, machine learning,
AI deep learning based
model, then cross-process
those results, and put forward
that metric into a database,
put forward that metric
into a dashboard,
or serve it to the customers.
But if you actually tried
to analyze what's going on,
an orchestration looks a
little bit more like that.
And you can think about
that linear workflow
like the solid
lines in this flow
here, in this orchestration.
We'd start with a
data validation,
actually doing some EDA, maybe
identifying the points of data
that you're actually going
to use to build models, what
models are you going to build.
And then you go into the
heavy compute costly piece
of the workflow, which is
where you train your models.
And you keep iterating
that until you get the best
model-- your optimal model.
That's where you'll
see sleepless nights
and several days spent
by a coffee field
data scientists just trying
to get the best model out.
Once that model is
out, maybe you're
going to attach, at the end of
it, the [INAUDIBLE] processing
phase, another ML workload.
You may classify something.
You may forecast something.
Or you're just going
to use heuristics
to detect an anomaly,
for instance,
in a predictive
maintenance use case.
And once you tune
that detectability,
once you tune that
classification,
you can deploy your metric.
Now if you're very lucky,
maybe you'll get user feedback.
And that's where you start
iterating over your cycles
and your loops.
So you get user feedback.
You retune your detectability.
And you're good to go.
If you're not that
lucky, maybe you
need to retrain, a little
bit, pieces of your models.
So you go one step back,
maybe use transfer learning,
and update parts of your
deep learning model.
And if you're not
lucky at all, you
go all the way back and have to,
basically, build a new model.
Try going and telling
the data scientists
that spent weeks on end that
that model was not great.
And we're going to have
to start all over again.
It's kind of complicated,
but sometimes happens.
So that's the reason
why, at Baker, we
started looking into ways
to automate this workflow
and give the data science a
more repeatable and scalable way
to build those models.
So when we tackle a
platform like the one
I showed before, we can build
several models in parallel,
instead of every time building
one model, and then two weeks
later, starting the next one.
That doesn't scale.
So let me talk about
that first loop
that we saw about
training models.
So we've, at Baker
Hughes, came up
with this probabilistic
evolutionary framework
of optimizing architectures
of deep learning models.
So when we go about building
TensorFlow based models
to detect anomaly,
for instance, we
don't want to just
go and randomly
search all the space available,
and just go and try to tune
the hyperparameters.
We want to make sure we
found our global best
model over parameter
combinations,
over architecture combinations.
And for that, what we do is
once we've built the model
and we explore,
intelligently, a space,
we build a meta-model of
the model's performance.
And then we apply
evolutionary methods
to that meta-model, which
is cheaper to compute.
So you start with red
dots, which are actually
heavy GPU, costly compute.
Then you create a meta-model.
And you apply the
evolutionary methods.
And then you just go and
burst these gray dots
and try to find the optimum.
If you keep doing that,
if you keep iterating,
if you keep the cycle, you
go from black to blue to red
to green, where
you get the minimum
of both of your objectives
or more than two objectives.
This gives us a 10x improvement
over just a random trial
and error research.
And we end up, actually,
exploring a quarter
of a million architectures.
And this is a pretty big,
beefy, big model space.
Now if you think that that is
done by custom scripts, that's
is also not scalable.
So for that, we use a
very nice tool from Google
called Kubeflow, which gives me
a way to Pythonically honestly
describe that orchestration.
So I can use Python objects
to define the operations that
are going to give me the
initial samples, then
the operation that
is going to give me
the next best models
through a genetic algorithm,
for instance, and the next
few points I'm sampling.
And I keep doing that.
And that's what you're
seeing on the screen.
So the first line is actually
120 deep learning models
being built concurrently
on a Kubernetes cluster.
And here we have to be
intelligent about using GPUs.
Because a single GPU
is very expensive.
Imagine having to have 120.
So we can, sometimes,
have split sessions
and run two or three
models per GPU.
And that's what we do here.
We go back in.
We optimize, find
the better points,
and keep doing that until
we find the best model.
But still, GPU are
very expensive.
So for that, we try to leverage
autoscaling applications
so that every time we need
an extra GPU, every time we
hit 80%, 90% of utilization
of our GPU in our clusters,
we give it another GPU.
And we keep scaling up
until the point where
we finish up the experiments,
we finish up the loops.
And here you see on the
bottom right hand corner
that we start with a
baseline that's probably
supporting other GPU workloads.
And as these optimization
starts, we climb.
And then we get them
down where we are just
running the genetic algorithm.
And we keep doing that
until we shut them all down.
This gets us to a
level of automation
of building deep
learning based models
that can help our customers,
now, in a reasonable time
frame, achieve those AI
based predictive maintenance
outcomes that they need.
Now this is not what
scale is all about.
And I'll leave it up
to Alex, my colleague,
to dig a little bit deeper
into what scale means.
ALEX IANKOULSKI:
Thank you, Fabio.
Hi, everyone.
I'm really excited to
have this opportunity
to talk to you
about Scale today.
In my talk, I will
use some analogies.
And I invite you to keep
an open mind and have fun.
So our challenge with
scale, to make everything
that Fabio just talked about
operate at really large scale.
Put in one word, was just
to be SMART about it.
So we needed to support
that typical workflow
that Fabio showed that
allows us to continue and not
disrupt the productivity
and the process
that data scientists
are already used to.
We needed to maintain
freedom of choice.
Because there is a huge
diversity of technologies
that have accumulated in
the oil and gas industry
over the past 30 years.
And we have to be able
to support all of them.
We need to keep things
simple to ensure
adoption of the platforms
we are building.
We have to be able to
readily package and deploy
to multiple targets,
including on prem,
data centers, and cloud.
And we have to run
all of this at scale,
be able to extract
insights, and prove
the value of these platforms.
So we made some choices
while building our platforms.
And the three major
ones are, first,
run everything in containers.
We tell our data
scientists, you can
do anything that you need to
do-- use the tools that you're
used to, the technologies that
help you get to your result.
But to productize the
fruits of your work,
just put everything
in a container.
And that is why we built
the Depend on Docker
project, which makes it easy for
anyone, even people who are not
familiar with Docker, to put
their software in a container,
be it Linux or Windows.
The second choice we made
is, keep compute and storage
completely separate.
That gives us very
nice flexibility,
ease of deployment, and
treating the compute
as something that's ephemeral.
Even if it goes completely away,
we can easily stand it back up
and bring the systems online.
It also allows us to scale.
And the third choice
is to orchestrate
all of these containers
using Kubernetes.
Today we're going to see a demo.
And for the purposes
of this demo,
we'll look at this use case.
We'll start with a data
file that has 20 variables.
And that is really a
collection of 20 time series.
So the answer that
we'll be looking
for is, what is the
very best model that you
can build using this data set?
Each one of these variables
can be the output variable.
And each one of the
rest of the variables
can be used to predict
that output variable.
So we'll go through
this workflow
to generate a large number
of model building jobs
to produce possible
models that can
be built with that data set.
And just for one file that
has 20 variables, when
all the combinations
are put together--
and we're also using
different modeling techniques.
So here, we're going to use six
So for 20 variables with
6 modeling techniques,
you get 120 models
that you can build.
To show scale, we're also
going to simulate 10 users
using 10 of these data files,
simultaneously, producing
a total of 1,200 models.
And that is a very, very
small use case for us.
To show you a little bit
about the architecture
we've put together to help
us do that, we basically
have three layers--
a storage layer, a layer
with core services,
and the run times.
So for the core services,
there is one thing
that I want to point out.
One of the lessons learned
when we were working on scaling
this up is that it is
necessary to break down
the services from
generalized services
to specialized services so each
individual microservice can
scale better.
So in the beginning, we had
the generic task service.
And that got split
into several components
of that task service,
which is, the first one,
responsible for watching
the Kubernetes' API.
The next one, responsible
for creating model jobs.
The next one, responsible for
collecting the results from
jobs that have completed.
The last one is responsible for
cleaning up after everybody.
So I can take the whole
time of this talk just going
over the points in this slide.
But I like doing things a lot
more than talking about them.
So we're just going to
hit the high points.
Lessons we've learned
from this exercise.
Large scale doesn't
come out of the box.
You will be required
to work for it.
And it's not a manual thing.
If you try to repeat
and do everything,
manually, you'll get very
tired pretty quickly.
And you'll start making
significant mistakes.
So automation and
scripting are key.
We already talked about breaking
down services to microservices.
[INAUDIBLE] services don't
lend themselves to scale.
And when you're talking
about large scale, 100x,
you have to be
prepared, to redesign,
and rethink what you're
doing, and maybe rewrite
several times.
"The Debate Between Cloud
Managed and Self Managed
Kubernetes."
I'm not going to go
too much into that.
But all I want to
say is that using GKE
can save you a lot of sleep.
There is this one really useful
Kubernetes API called the Watch
API, which lets you monitor
the status of your pods
and get real-time events as
changes happen in your cluster.
So we're making use
of that in our demo.
Also we had made an assumption
that it is enough to,
I just scale my
service in Kubernetes,
and then, traffic will
be distributed evenly.
And all the pods we'll
be happy to handle
an equal amount of traffic.
That is not the case.
You actually have
to do some work
to get proper load
balancing in Kubernetes.
We were seeing that
some of our pods
were getting so much traffic,
they were literally, killed
and had to restart.
And others were
just sitting there.
So Envoy proxy
solved that problem
using the Google Native
cloud load balancer
solved that problem.
I want to caution you.
Watch out for the
less is more paradox.
So in our desire to
scale everything so high,
we said, all right, let's
run 100 of this service
and 1,000 of that service
and 2,000 of that one.
We even scaled one up to 8,000.
And things actually
slowed down instead
of giving us better results.
So you really have
to think and optimize
for what is good
for your system,
and realize that,
sometimes, less is more.
Last lesson I
learned that will--
actually, bring me back
to the next slide--
is, sometimes one
Kubernetes cluster is not
enough to accomplish
what you're trying to do.
So when that's the
case, just use many.
So for the purposes
of today's demo,
we have built for you a
cluster of Kubernetes clusters.
What you see here is our
master Kubernetes cluster
that has all of the
services that I showed you
in the previous
slide, scaled up.
And this, in itself, gives
you a scalable system.
Because you can scale
horizontally by running more
nodes in your cluster.
You can scale vertically
by running larger nodes
in your cluster.
But what we've done gives you
another degree of freedom.
Because you can run
as many Kubernetes
clusters as you want
to handle your load.
So now you can spread
your system really wide.
And by the way,
remember how I talked
about self managed versus GKE?
Here we have done both.
So it is not required.
We can run all of our
workloads on GKE or all of them
on Kubernetes.
But we're going to show you
both just because we can?
So this is an example of
one of our GKE clusters?
It has 100 nodes.
And it's ready for us
to run workloads on.
I'm going to zoom
out a little bit.
These are five GKE clusters.
So remember how I said
I'll make some analogies?
What does this remind you of?
Let me zoom out one more time.
On the top, live
five GKE clusters.
In the middle is our
management cluster.
And on the bottom, are
five self managed clusters.
I don't know about you.
But to me, this looks
like a skyscraper.
OK.
Let's take a look at how
everything looks on screen.
So I have split my
screen, here, in two
just so I can show you
our management cluster.
I will-- wow, this
is really slow.
I just want to show you
that things are actually
running here.
I'm also going to show
you at what scale we're
running our core services.
And let me zoom this
out a little bit.
So you can say some instances
have 1,000, some 500 instances.
Now we have modified the
Kubernetes dashboard.
So we can also visually show
you what the scale looks like.
And so we've added
this graph tab
to the Kubernetes dashboard.
And that is the
visual representation
of what we just saw.
That's only the master cluster.
I will zoom into this area here.
So each of the triangles
in this chart is a service.
And each of the dots are
pods from that service that
are running in the cluster.
Let's take a look at
the worker clusters.
So here I have--
let me show you this.
We'll use a very nifty tool
called Kubectx lets you easily
show what are the Kubernetes
contexts that you're
looking at.
So on the left, you'll see
each of these sessions pointing
to one of the GKE
clusters, 1 through 5.
And on the right, we have 5 self
managed Kubernetes contexts.
So I'm going to show you what's
running in these clusters
by watching the command
Kubectl get pods.
And what's running is
absolutely nothing.
But that's a good thing.
Because we can't
visualize it yet.
So if we were to use that
Kubernetes dashboard and wanted
to visualize a low workload
that is running in 10 Kubernetes
clusters, what are
we going to do?
Install it in each
one of the clusters,
and then have 10 screens up?
Then what if we had 100
Kubernetes clusters?
That doesn't scale.
So we've built a custom UI that
aggregates all the information
from the clusters and displays
it in a single user interface.
Right now, I'm just going
to show you that one
cluster we have running pods.
That's the master cluster.
Let me pull the dots
together a little bit.
Let's slow down,
make them bigger.
So these are the service
pods that we have
running in the master cluster.
We're going to-- oh, I
see what's going on here.
OK.
We're going to use Docker
Compose to simulate
these 10 different users, each
of them using a different data
file of 20 variables each,
to submit to the guided
build API, 120 models.
So let me see what this
will remind you of.
It's colorful, isn't it?
Isn't it funny how things
in the real world remind us
of things that scale
in the virtual world?
So here is the
workload of these jobs
that we submitted being
distributed between all
of the Kubernetes clusters.
And let's take a look
at our rainbow here.
Well, as it happens,
the demo gods
are not always in favor of us.
But that is why we
have screenshots.
[LAUGHTER]
You can see the workload
here much better anyway.
And this is what
these 1,200 models
look like when that got created
in all the 10 Kubernetes
clusters.
So I once saw a
demonstration of somebody
building a lot of containers
and running a lot of containers
in a cluster.
And that visualization
was beautiful.
And it honestly looked
to me like a galaxy.
So when I saw this one for
the first time at scale,
I thought that each one
of these little clusters
looks like a galaxy.
So I made a comment
to my team, guys, I
think we've inadvertently
modeled the universe.
(LAUGHING)
If you want to see this demo
at bigger scale, 10x and 100x,
I invite you, after
this talk, to move
to the next hallway,
room 11, where
you'll be able to see this
running at much larger scale.
So let me see if we can--
I'm going to stop it.
And we'll see-- this is--
yeah.
Things are being created.
But, yeah.
It's beautiful, isn't it?
The ocean of data that
Fabio talked about is real.
And being able to
extract that answer, what
is the best model, what is
the meaningful information
in this ocean of
data, is actually not
very straightforward.
But that is the reason
why we did all of this.
So let me run a query here.
So we can get our answer.
The answer will come
up once all the metrics
get accumulated and ranked.
Because we started with a
completely blank system,
we don't have the answer yet.
However, what I
wanted to point out
is that, as in many
things in science,
the answer to the question,
what is the best model, is,
it depends.
If you used the criteria
of root mean square error,
then the answer is 1.
If you used max
percentage error,
then you might get
a different model--
or average percentage error.
I do want to leave you with
a few things to take home.
First of all, real world
use cases require scale.
We demonstrated
orchestration and analytics.
We showed you
screenshots of scale.
We used Docker, Kubernetes,
TensorFlow, and Kubeflow
on scalable infrastructure
and managed services
from Google Cloud.
I also want to leave
you with something
that I'd like you to
remember this talk by.
A year, two years from
now when you think back
about Fabio and Alex from BHGE
that talked about orchestrating
of containers and
scaling things up,
this is the one
talk where you saw
how to use skyscrapers and
rainbows to model the galaxy.
[LAUGHTER]
I would like to read
out some names here.
On this slide, we have a small
thank you for some big names.
Arun, Andre,
Renato, [INAUDIBLE],,
Christian, Imran, Murali,
Mahadevan, Simon, Trang,
Raheid, Alex, Kelsey, Sina,
Yang, Ning, Tad, Josh, Scott,
Will, and many more.
Thank you for collaborating
and encouraging us.
We have a page full
of references for you.
Anyone who would
like to read more
and who has doubts about what
we're showing here today,
please refer to these links.
And you can always get in
touch with Fabio and I offline.
But if you have any questions
that you would like to ask us
now, please pick a mic.
And we'll do the best
we can to answer.
Thank you.
FABIO NONATO: Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
- A network connectivity issue
prevented the demonstration
in this session from
working flawlessly.
The issue was
mitigated immediately
after the presentation.
In order to provide
you the full experience
of this amazing capability,
we have recorded
the following additional video.
[END PLAYBACK]
[MUSIC PLAYING]